[Music]
hello there affair okay yeah this works
that's fine
hello hello that's it okay now I'm a
star I'm done thank you okay
today I'm going to be talking about
JavaScript is for everyone that wasn't
supposed to happen
[Applause]
and also that wasn't supposed to happen
okay hello I'm Ken economist Steven
i'ma front-end engineering lead and
developer advocate at be Custer
I'm also the are convenient community
manager for Corps d'Afrique I'll be
telling you about the Kota freak story
and why javascript is for everyone you
can find me on Twitter expenses TV
please don't ask me how I came about
that handle it's one of those things I
don't really want to talk about but yeah
I walk in Finland who knows about
Finland oh that's nice this audience is
way better in Finland we don't smile so
it's like do you know about Finland
that's pretty much it but yeah I'm going
to be talking about JavaScript in for
everyone and this is basically how it's
going to go I'm going to tell you about
what could have ik is I'm going to tell
you why we do what we do important
disclaimer you might not necessarily
like a lot of things I'm going to say
today oh I think it's important to
actually state this things out because
there's been a huge function between
teaching JavaScript and gets in
beginners into the industry I'm going to
talk about the team behind coda freak
I'm going to be telling you how we teach
JavaScript
I'm going to tell you about ember how
convention server configurations have
changed for us I'm going to give you an
example beginner concepts that we
actually used ember to do I'm going to
give a history a brief history of where
we came from and how we decided to go
with this and I'm gonna show you what
we're going to be doing moving forward
so what on earth is go to freak well
we're not in fancy just a regular bunch
of software engineers giving back to the
underrepresented folk community it's a
bunch of students we all met when we at
the University of Tartu doing a master's
in software engineering we figured out
the problem in Estonia and we decided to
get together to solve it so yeah I'm
gonna tell you about that what we did
what do we do and why do you do what we
do who understands what this means okay
very few hands but this basically
explains why I'm giving this walk in
case you missed it in my previous slide
I used the word once I represented it
was highlighted in red for a specific
reason
I would like to redefine this word I
would not like to be addressed with this
word I see myself as a marginalized
person so in 2015 I was doing a master's
in software engineering in Estonia we
had a lot of people of color in these in
the country but not so many but very few
but quite significant number the issue
was it was difficult to get jobs right
there are a lot of people who wanted to
get into the tech space or it was
difficult to get in and the reason was
we have created this various for them
assuming that everyone had the same
cognitive abilities and this is this is
a bias that a lot of us have we don't
necessarily do it intentionally but this
is it and just a random question how
many people who make tutorials or teach
people think about learning disabilities
like ADHD for example very few hands how
many people think about people who are
not really able to learn not because
they're not smart enough but because
they didn't have the same privileges
that you had do you ever think of that
how many people here got their first
computers before 15 okay you see this
hands I never got a computer before 15
so whether I like it or not I didn't get
the advantages that order had and this
is why we came about could a freak to
actually try to reach that gap and give
people the ability to actually get into
the industry without thinking so much
yesterday something happened and I
basically wanted to quote this I thought
it was important because I would like to
change the narrative of we being
underrepresented I quote Bryan Liles
when he says we are not going to
represent that anymore
y'all overrepresented
but this is fact
we're black indigenous people of color
in IT and we're supposed to be here
we're not here as a quota we're here
because we were supposed to be we no
longer want to be using negatives to
address ourselves in industry we want to
be seen as people who are marginalized
we're not underrepresented that's not
the way we want to see and hopefully I
hope that at the end of this talk
everyone takes this back and puts that
at the back of their minds would you
believe if I tell you there's a lot of
amazing ideas that never see the light
of day just because the idea idea tour
is basically a person of color or
belongs to a marginalized community how
many people actually believe this it's
always difficult when you need to go and
swap for font when you belong to a
specific demographic it's not as easy as
a lot of people think this is one of the
reasons why we decided we wanted to
create this community where we brought
people together people who belong to
this underrepresented groups and then
teach them JavaScript in such a way
where they don't need to be so much
worried about the toxicity we have in
the industry they could just come and
lend and afterwards explore so yeah like
everyone else I think we all deserve an
equal chance it might not be nice it
might not be comfortable for some people
but we all do develop deserve equal
chance well I'm not really sure about
peace and workers so maybe pizza and
burgers don't deserve equal lining I'm a
pizza person so maybe the Americans
might not be super happy but I like
pizza more than burgers so let's meet
the theme like I said we're just a bunch
of regular people the folks who work at
coda freak that's Gabriel this is Sunday
and this is Victor they're all senior
software engineers two of them work in
Canada and one works in Estonia we
started coda freak together in 2016 and
we've been going stronger ever since I'm
gonna give a horrible mention to a
friend called fortunate he's from Congo
he also based in Estonia he has really
helped us a lot and he basically helped
us discover a better way to actually
accommodate people when we need to teach
JavaScript now one of the biggest things
we found out about javascript in getting
people into the industry is that the
conceptions are pure evil
one of the preconception is that
JavaScript is easy you can say that when
you're not a beginner if you have never
written a line of code programming is
never as easy as you think and this is
something I want also always remember
when you have to teach people the fact
that you understand it does not
necessarily mean they will understand it
the way that you do the fact that you
have the ability to assimilate things
does not necessarily mean they would
have the ability to assimilate since the
way that you will as you just the
JavaScript community out here is there's
no guarantee way of ensuring people
grasp the concepts this isn't a fault
with JavaScript at all this is just
purely down to the fact that people
learn differently and we where we have
made the mistake is not really taking
time to find ways to accommodate the
different type of people we need to
learn we have been very mainstream in
the way we teach JavaScript and I'm
hoping that as we go back today for
those of us who meant to people for
those of us who have junior developers
we kind of take this into consideration
about who we are teaching what the
situations might be sometimes it's not
only about learning disabilities it
could be emotional
it could be mental it could be physical
so let's always be died into
consideration when we need to teach now
JavaScript doesn't have to be
complicated as much as we tend to make
it complicated I strongly believe it
doesn't have to be javascript is a
beautiful language I didn't come from a
JavaScript background I came from a C++
background but ever since I've got here
I don't want to go back because I love
being here
however we have created a barrier that
makes it difficult for people to come
into the industry and just before I go a
quick question how many people here work
in front-end development awesome that's
a lot of hands okay this should have
been named just confronting how many
people as front-end engineers have had
to traverse a binary tree in the regular
day jobs okay that's very few hands
that's I can't even count how many
people have had to use the big
o-notation in the regular jobs of
front-end engineers okay it's also very
few hands now think about it why do we
need to actually make
Guinness scared of getting into the
industry by bombarding them with all
this information instead of getting them
in and easing them into learning why
can't we do that why do we always have
to make it so complicated so we designed
a very simple way to actually teach
beginners and it's basically this
because whether you like it or not these
are the three building blocks of
JavaScript the moment you can understand
these three concepts it makes it easier
for you to go on to explore different
other things we basically decided to use
this button explaining variables and
objects and methods going through this
way we think it's easier it has worked
for us it has enabled us to get out the
15 students we initially check get nine
of them into the industry the good
engineers they're still young they still
have a lot of time to improve but
they're learning and it's shown us that
there's a possibility to actually ease
people into the industry without
necessarily complicating the entrance we
need to think about the different type
of people we need to think about the
different communities we need to find a
way to get everyone in without
necessarily unintentionally excluding
them now the biggest problem we face
when we need to teach people and this is
not this is by no means me lashing out
at anyone or any particular thing I'm
just saying the JavaScript community has
grown so big and something that is
supposed to be a huge help for us hasn't
done on unfortunately turned out to be a
problem and what's that this is it yeah
and again pretty much frameworks
frameworks were supposed to make
software development easy frameworks
were basically unable to do it we
started building frameworks to enable
people become productive easier
unfortunately we have started making
frameworks that by making it more
complicated for people to get in and
this is now lash out to anyone or any
framework in my team we use four
different JavaScript frameworks with
different projects
every one has its pros and cons but I
think that it's important that when we
build this and even when we make
tutorial so whichever frameworks we use
we take into consideration the different
type of people that need to lend now I
like Ember and I'm going to make an
important disclaimer and binary way
connected to the Ember community I am
NOT the contributor to remember I am
only speaking about ember in the context
of how we actually use them to teach
people by just giving simple
instructions
there's something very controversial
about ember I wouldn't say controversial
I will say it's a diverse opinion and
it's a convention over configuration a
lot of people feel that this is not so
good and that's not justified they have
the reasons a lot of people who do
believe that convention over
configuration it's also quite important
and they have the reasons now starting
in Cola freak we actually went ahead to
teach people in terms of the different
things that we needed to show them and
what we discovered was that it was
easier to actually use ember because we
could give them a set of instructions to
follow and if you remember that one of
the most important things you enjoyed as
a beginner was rights in that first line
of code and seen it work so we give them
an opportunity to actually see their
walk progress enjoy that excitement and
then go on to dig deeper behind the
basics why this works the way it works
instead of watering so much in the other
reverse pattern so typical pitfalls we
encountered with trying to use other
frameworks lazy loading there were too
many computer science concepts at
front-end development it doesn't have to
be so complicated come on some framework
seems to be front-end frameworks
designed for back-end developers a lot
of people here I can agree with that I'm
pretty sure we've all been there we've
all seen it we probably know what I'm
talking about
yeah and then some things are not just
designed for beginners it's true as much
as we would like to say it is it's just
not designed for beginners it's not
beginner friendly there are tons of
other things but I'm going to skip that
and just talk about the basic ones at
this point I'm going to play a nice
video
okay so I'm just going to round up that
was pretty much it I would say big thank
you to all the people who work with my
guides teaching em and teaching v-j as
our students have been totally amazing
mostly because of the way the
documentation is actually designed huge
shout out to this to your communities
the documentation totally amazing and
they make teaching easy for us
so our wins thanks to member routers and
this is no beef against any framework
but not having to teach people about
routes in not having to tell people
listen I need you to go and install this
particular framework router to get
started
helps us a lot because it needs the need
for people to worry about that when they
want to learn about routers they will do
that on their own time what they
interested in is getting productive and
making code so that's what we help them
do handlebars we're grateful for these
mostly because of the way the nobles
also data-binding
we can't actually teach data binding
without worrying about teaching data
binding and basically they can get
productive they can understand it and
when they want to dig deeper they have a
better overview of what data binding
should be and how it should work
and lastly convention we all have we all
have different ideas about convention
but as someone who has thoughts Ruby and
rails and taught em ideas and put
JavaScript even in a university I
actually think for beginners and
considering different types of learners
it's actually important to give them a
certain set of guidelines for them to
use in working that way it's easier for
them to follow up and also be productive
and just I'm going to show a couple of
little things so this is pretty much
lazy loading in ember.js this is how
straightforward it is I only need to
explain what lazy loading is and show
them this and that's pretty much it now
no disrespect to angular but if I need
to do this in angular it's not so
straightforward and these are one of the
issues that we normally face when we
need to teach because you need to make
sure that you can go into a lot of very
core concepts going into a lot of core
concepts for people who you are trying
to get into the industry might just be a
way to chase them away so using simpler
methods using these kind of methods and
using convention over configuration we
can actually do this
show it to them better I really hope
that a lot of frameworks will try to
coexist and make it easier for people
who are getting into the industry and
this is basically a simple routing
function and I'm betrayus and this is a
simple explanation this is all I need to
tell a student that how the routes in
itself would work and this would
actually make logical sense because it
follows systematically the way it will
flow and lastly this is a code written
by someone who learns JavaScript for
four days he had literally just lent
objects variables and functions and then
he came up with this I promised him that
I was going to put this up there because
I think four days into learning
programming I'm pretty sure I couldn't
write this so somehow we are actually
doing something right and I'm hoping
that as we go back we learn to actually
help people learn properly and moving
forward with River and encoded freak to
reload we still have got a freaker's an
online version but we load this a full
time class it's a free intensive boot
camp for people who identify for any
marginalized groups you can find us on
Twitter and if you would like to be a
mentor to some of our students that'll
be totally amazing for us we would love
that and many thanks to the following
organizations destitution of African
students in Estonia they gave us the
first classroom that we needed thanks to
the Italian University of Technology I
was a guest lecturer there and they
helped us also get a classroom our
classrooms are located in the Metro
innovation Institute and huge thanks to
my company I'm paid to be a developer
advocate that doesn't need to come and
talk about be caster but to come and
talk about what we do at could a freak
so huge thanks to them and lastly I just
wanted to mention about mentoring
because this is also a fundamental part
of JavaScript that we have actually
forgotten now a huge shout out to the
node.js community they have an awesome
mentoring system it does have a little
floor and hopefully some time I'm going
to bring that up when I can but I just
wanted to point out that if you know you
meant to anyone if you know you're a
senior engineer and you have junior
engineers in your team mentor mean is
not good enough you need to open them to
your network you need to give them
opportunities it's one thing to
say yeah I'm a teacher I have four
mentees how many of you men's is
actually working how many of them are
you giving the opportunity to actually
learn about public speaking so for me I
think it's important that we keep this
at the back of our minds while we teach
it's one thing to past knowledge is
another thing to give people the
confidence while you mentor people open
them up to your network give them
opportunities I I used to be at fault
for this because I have I had a lot of
men since I had seven of them and none
of them were working at some point right
and I had to go back and see that and
think okay maybe this is not the right
approach maybe I'm missing something and
what was I missing opening them to my
network so on LinkedIn if I see your job
I'd show it to them listen you should
take it take a shot at this and I can
comfortably say all seven of them are
working today one is soon going to be a
senior engineer he's just been three
years but he's pretty smart because he
has a CS background so it's also
important that we open people up to our
networks I'm highlighting this meant
this mentees that we have caught a freak
because they came from a very different
background he's a journalist and when I
look down there she actually also
doesn't have a CS degree
she studied marketing but they all
engineers now and we're really proud of
what they do and I hope we can encourage
more people to get into tech this way
and lastly I'm just going to point this
who has had this phrase before okay so
basically what this means it's that it's
all about sharing what's been bothering
you for a long time mostly things that
you know you usually don't have anyone
to talk about but you would like to talk
about it and the reason why I do this is
because every time I come to a
conference I have students who are back
home listening and I want the experience
developers here to please help me go on
Twitter and talk about your most
vulnerable met your most vulnerable
times talk about those things that you
can't remember you can go into either a
for example every single time I need to
Google how to use the reduce function
because despite the fact that I've been
programming for over five years I don't
seem to grab it I have to go and still
check out the reduce function I might be
good at all the things but when you say
they see too young
or it doesn't matter the age but people
who are young in industry you give them
some sort of confidence and make them
know that okay we are not all Superman
you know everyone basically makes
mistakes you know everyone has some part
that not they're not so comfortable with
right so I want you to please share your
stories I'm gonna go and tweet too
quickly and I'm gonna post this so
please indulge me I prepared this tweet
just ahead of time you can go under and
write the things that you consider to be
the most vulnerable things you know as a
senior developer what things do you
forget regularly as a senior developer
one of the things I've noticed is that
no matter how much I think I know I
really don't know
unfortunately because I when I went to
see amber conce i sat with yahudah and
he's someone that's been a role model
for me I have thought my reading his
code right from Ruby when he started
contributing to Ruby on Rails you know
and I sit down with him I have
conversation and I realize like oh boy I
have a long way to go you know so please
share your stories with them encourage
them and make them understand that it's
it's it's okay to make mistakes we all
make mistakes regardless of how many
years experience we have in the industry
everyone makes mistakes and everyone
learns from them and you can do better
and I'm sorry I started going back and
with that I say thank you you can find
me on github and Twitter and you can
send me an email and the word you see
there ketose is the one thing I want you
to learn about Finland today this is how
we say thank you so thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]